Bonjour c'est Cyprien, aujourd'hui je vais faire une vidéo sur la SNCF sans évoquer le retard des trains.
C'est une première, on a jamais vu ça en France
Je prends assez souvent le train, j'ai moins de 25 ans
J'ai donc une carte 12-25 appelé aussi la carte que tu oublies tout le temps
Ca fait des années que je l'ai, je la change tous les ans
et je l'oublie à chaque fois
pas une seule fois je l'ai sur moi
Alors j'ai trouvé une solution
Merci! Votre carte de réduction s'il vous plait
Ah la Voilà
Je me la suis greffé sur le corps, voilà comme ça je peux plus l'oublier
J'ai fait pareil avec ma carte Navigo
Mais avant de monter dans le train, il faut composter son billet
C'est obligatoire, c'est vite fait de composter un billet, ça prend quoi?
35 minutes
Et là la machine te demande tout le temps de retourner ton billet
ça ne change absolument rien
Et quand enfin j'ai réussi à composter mon billet
C'est là que je remarque qu'il était précomposté
Je suis un boulet
Alors y'a pleins de choses que je n'aime dans la SNCF
la machine à composter, le wagon-bar
Ah on dirait que votre sandwich est périmé
C'est pas la date de péremption?
Je vous le rends en fait j'ai perdu ma carte bleu
Désolé. En revoir
Mais c'est pas pour autant que je vais me mettre à frauder
je paie tous mes billets tout ça parce que la fraude
c'est pas fait pour moi
Bonjou, est-ce que je pourrais
Ouah j'avoue tout, c'est moi, enfermez moi
je mérite pas de vivre
C'était pour récupérer mon sac qui est à côté de vous s'il vous plait
Bien sur
Y'a un autre truc qui me fait extrêmement flippé dans les trains
je ne dors jamais dans un train
Voilà, jamais je peux être l'homme le plus fatigué du monde
Non je ne dors pas
Pour une raison extremement simple
Gare de Bamako 2 minutes d'arrêt, gare de Bamako, je répète gare de Bamako 2 minutes d'arrêt
Et le plus gros mystère de la SNCF pour moi
c'est quand le train est arrêté sur la voie
et qu'on entend ça
Le train est actuellement arrêté sur la voie. pour votre sécurité, veuillez ne pas tenter d'ouvrir les portes
Attendez
ça veut dire
qu'on peut ouvrir les ports, c'est ça?
j'entends ça j'ai envie d'essayer
Hein c'est complètement con comme message
je suis sûr qu'il y a des gens qui meurent tous les jours à cause de ça
Bah oui
j'en étais sûr, ça
Si vous avez quelque chose contre la SNCF ou si la SNCF a quelque chose contre vous,
partagez ma vidéo sur Facebook et rejoignez ma page aussi
Hein on s'amuse comme des fous
Barbecue tous les midis
Mes autres vidéos sont sur Cyprien.fr
je sais pas pourquoi je chuchotte
Et puis finalement ils me cassent les couilles à toujours être en retard